get your coat grab you have because
we're going to take you to the land of
glass nose perestroika and Egg McMuffins
we're a two-time Academy Award winners
waiting at the receive concert hall
which is just to the left of the Kremlin
if that's possible I just made that up
so yeah move on we need more school I
can see myself
you
wait a minute I gotta get this right so
but ie autre and now that be am i right
that means good morning because here
right now
it is [ __ ] but it's five minutes of 7:00
a.m. Tuesday morning as a new dawning in
Moscow ways that I have a peculiar
little prepare a Tribune I guess it's
just for luck but when I'm shooting a
film before the cameras turn on a scene
I always say magic time well right here
right now in Moscow it is magic time
here we are representing the Academy
Awards Russia from the Soviet Union live
for the very foot I'm and who would ever
and I think it's only fitting that would
through films because in movies your
dreams do come true
and speaking of dreams I would like to
introduce you to my co-host a marvelous
young actress she won the Soviet Academy
Award last year for her performance in
little Vera the very talented and very
charming and very beautiful
Natalia Nagada
thank you for that lovely introduction
mr. lemon isn't that a beautiful echo
what mr. lemon nobody please call me
comrade very well comment okay now I
understand that our distinguished guests
here our artists that are members of the
of the Soviet film Workers Union yes
Jack they are righteous actors directors
producers and critics wait with the
critics of the union protection yes I
addressed
carrying glass notes a little far and
then now you make what a hundred and
fifty films in Russia each year and the
ticket for admission cost seventy copass
right now how much is that in American
energy American money hmm
12 cents dresses half a Hollywood just
had a heart attack and a hundred million
people go to always every year 100
million but that's a hell on Williams
day how many of your films show a profit
profit profit in Russia whenever here's
is what profit you're welcome to the
club welcome now to business the
nominees for the best foreign language
film are from France
Camille Claudel
from Italy Cinema Paradiso
oh Jesus of Montreal from Velma Walton
rig itself
whether ego whatever happen to San Diago
Russ a tri-corner house man just sailed
down the bolger with an envelope in may
I have the envelope please god bless you
sir you're a wonderful person
oh and the Oscar goes to Italy for
cinema paradiso
where to but we will be very very fast
evidently March 26 is my lucky day 15
years ago I was here to receive an Oscar
for Fellini summer code and they came in
this hole with the beautiful young
ladies jod who I married later and
exactly March 26 so today I'm doubly
happy because of the Oscar and because
tonight and the niversary date my wife
is here in the auditorium thank you
thanks thanks a lot of you thanks to mr.
Tornatore and excuse me thank to myself
what is the pictures
the 62nd annual Academy Awards will be
back with Kevin Kline and Daryl Hannah